après des mois de surenchère et une
augmentation de plus de 50% des prix des
propriétés en deux ans la frénésie
immobilière
auraient-elles maintenant atteint un
sommet c'est ce qu'affirme en tout cas
plusieurs experts on en parle ce soir
avec robert hogue économiste en chef
adjoint de la rdc bonsoir
oui bonsoir robert hogue qu'est ce qui
fait dire peut-être à certains agents
immobiliers puis à des économistes que
nous avons peut-être atteint un sommet
en termes de croissance des prix
en fait lorsqu'on commence à regarder ce
qui s'en vient on venait juste d'en
parler la hausse des taux d'intérêts
communs avoirs à la banque du canada qui
va annoncer une hausse de taux c'est
presque a suivi ça va ça vient d'un
quart de point ou de l'imi points et se
sent pas fini la veille à voir d'autres
choses qui vont s'en venir dans l'est
dans les mois à venir donc je pense que
lorsqu'on regarde ça dans tom de
facteurs qui a contribué ça à la
surenchère et à la paix un marché qui a
été extrêmement tendues au cours
particulièrement de la pandémie là je
pense que le vent que le vent va
commencer à changer de côté il va y
avoir c'est s'efforcer de tourner
directement commencé à exercer une
pression à la baisse sur la demande qui
va éventuellement se matérialiser il
avait que des hausses de prix qui vont
seulement qu'ils vont sûrement commencer
à ralentir on constate déjà de l'ailé
donné qu'on a jusqu'à présent le mois de
mars les prix continuent d'augmenter ma
pas tout à fait au même rythme que
c'était au cours des mois précédents ça
pour être ce qui est qu'est le point
tournant dans un certain sens alors le
facteur taux d'intérêt est très
important c'est un un des facteurs
principaux bien sûr qui pourrait
provoquer un revirement de la situation
mais c'est pas le seul robert hogue
ben non il t'as mal on a eu un budget la
semaine dernière un budget fédéral qui à
cannes on sait beaucoup de choses au
sujet de l'application parce qu'on
regarde ce à l'échelle du pays il ya
d'autres gouvernements provinciaux aussi
qui la semaine précédente avait annoncé
certaines mesures un peu de resserrement
on passe à montferrier haut avec sas
attaques sur les non résidents
également aussi en nouvelle écosse alors
soumise ensemble c'est qu'il ya des
ensembles de nombre de mesures qui sont
en place
quand même avouer que le budget fédéral
dans matière de petites actions de cette
ago un groupement avec ben whishaw nous
allons sans doute que ça va laisser les
marchés les porter à vouloir
analyser soeur et de vouloir gérer tous
ces mesures la ville sans doute
la réflexion si vous voulez mais
d'ailleurs j'aimerais ça vous entendre
qu est ce que vous en pensez par exemple
des mesures on a beaucoup parlé de
l'accès à la propriété ce fameux celi
habitations achat d'une première
propriété est ce que ça va aider à
l'accès à la propriété selon vous
ça reste à voir bien sûr parce qu'il
faut bien comprendre aussi que
c'est une mesure qui vaut pas entre en
vigueur demain observable qui va pas
avoir un impact ça marche inserm alors
ça ça ferait pas les prochaine
génération d'acheteurs si vous voulez
pas pouvoir éventuellement faire
l'entrée d'antoine marché alors c'est
sûr faut voir ça comme un impact qui va
être graduelle un peu plus long terme m
16 ça va sans doute pas changé la donne
du cycle actuel les achats qui sont
présentement ou les personnes qui
aimeraient bien pouvoir le marché
présentement alors ça c'est plutôt un
horizon qui est un petit peu plus à long
terme ici on est dans un marché de
vendeurs quand même depuis des années il
ya des marchés également que sont
saturés on pense à toronto on pense à
vancouver surtout les deux villes où les
prix de l'immobilier sont les plus
élevés est ce que est ce que les prix
vont finir par arrêter de monter et même
baissé et est ce que la tendance marché
de vendeurs pourraient s'inverser
c'est absolument pas exclure en fait
nous on s'attend ce que justement ces
puces se ralentir ces hausses de prix là
faut bien comprendre je reviens encore
une fois c'est la hausse des taux
d'intérêt
un énorme facteur lorsqu'on calcule par
exemple un pas que ça va avoir les
paiements mensuels de ce quelqu'un qui
arrive dans le marché présentement une
hausse d'impôts un point de pourcentage
des taux d'intérêt à l'échelle du pays
on parle d'ici sa fin segment clé les
paiements mensuels depuis 300 $ sur une
maison type à l'échelle du pays donc ses
trousses c'est un gros défi à savoir
réduire également le budget le budget
des acheteurs parce que le taux de
qualification commencé à augmenter
également alors ça va sa voix sans doute
menu certaines personnes hors du marché
les garder à l'extérieur du marchix pss
d'avoir exercé un certain effet de
refroidissement et au québec et à
montréal comment on peut penser que le
marché va se comporter
ces marchés ne sont pas libres et les
taux d'intérêt encore une fois le savoir
l'impact de taux d'intérêt savoir à
l'échelle du pays ceci dit évidemment
les marchés les plus chers les ou de
rouler la taille des hypothèques sont
les plus grands c'est ce sont ces
marchés d'actions les plus sensibles à
des hausses des taux d'intérêt longs
penser
à toronto où elles vont vers montréal
n'est pas tout à fait au québec son
portefeuille dans ces classes la memoria
quand même la portabilité s'est
détériorée locaux va particulièrement
cool deux dernières années alors ça va
se savoir savoir rendre les choses un
peu plus un peu plus difficile également
être pas tout à fait dans la même
échelle que
donc à surveiller si je comprends bien
votre propos là c'est vraiment la banque
du canada qui allie les deux mains sur
le volant et qui à la manette en main
pour tenter de calmer le marché du
mobilier
c'est comme les bas taux d'intérêt d'un
homme un secteur que stimuler la demande
depuis le début de la saison versement
au quai robert hogue merci
ça m'a fait plaisir
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit